Caption: uh so we have for our first Speaker here
Caption: we have Cornell stain uh Cornell is a
Caption: service and experienced designer that
Caption: loves creating clarity through research
Caption: and experimenting to bring products to
Caption: life
Caption: it is his first time speaking at DDD so
Caption: he's very excited please be very kind
Caption: and I'll hand you over to Cornell to
Caption: talk about feature trees yeah thank you
Caption: very much
Caption: so I've never used one of these I called
Caption: them earlier like a Beyonce mic and
Caption: because my name is Cornell it's like a
Caption: coriance mic so we're just gonna roll
Caption: with it so yeah I'm just gonna just jump
Caption: straight in so I want to talk to you
Caption: today about feature trees and that's
Caption: what this entire talk is about before we
Caption: do um if we just mentioned this is my
Caption: first time speaking at DDD last year was
Caption: my first time attending DDD so me being
Caption: here is yeah it's just absolutely crazy
Caption: for me
Caption: um the sponsors made this day possible
Caption: and it's yeah this knowledge Community
Caption: we have here in Perth is just absolutely
Caption: amazing so thanks for learning with me
Caption: I'm learning about this topic as well so
Caption: yeah just again I'm going to say this a
Caption: few times thank you for allowing me to
Caption: share today
Caption: so I have a bone to pick with you
Caption: you did this you voted for this talk so
Caption: you know like why are we here that kind
Caption: of thing so this is in place of the
Caption: agenda slide so what's all this thing so
Caption: today I want to take you through first
Caption: of all what is a feature tree why I use
Caption: it in my workflow when I'm designing and
Caption: building products and why sort of a
Caption: central artifact for teams to Rally
Caption: around and then also I'm going to share
Caption: some tips and tricks from how you create
Caption: them and you'll also hear today a few
Caption: cornellisms I don't write scripts for my
Caption: talks it's just incompatible with my
Caption: nerves so I'm just gonna wig it but
Caption: within reason of course so let's um Jump
Caption: Right In for me the gold standard of a
Caption: featured tree is that of up so up is a
Caption: digital bank quick show of hands anyone
Caption: with up
Caption: yeah they're pretty cool I probably
Caption: should change to them so let's imagine
Caption: up that app in your pocket that is the
Caption: product I'm going to use a lot of sort
Caption: of agile product service design kind of
Caption: language here today so if you hear some
Caption: of that language that's where that comes
Caption: from but up that is the product the
Caption: product is the tree the thing that your
Caption: users see so that's the end goal
Caption: visualizing the product
Caption: next up we've got a set of features
Caption: that's the functionality everything
Caption: that's built that the user can interact
Caption: with what's built they sum to the tree
Caption: so that's where the Roots come from the
Caption: tree pretty simple concept and then we
Caption: go into the detail of a specific feature
Caption: so here we've got for example the
Caption: feature of a payment and on the bottom
Caption: right you'll see a key so you've got
Caption: stuff like what's being built or what's
Caption: in progress what have we already done
Caption: what's coming up or what have we pruned
Caption: what are we not building sometimes it's
Caption: nice to visualize that so for example in
Caption: this very specific example we've got
Caption: making a payment of course it's a
Caption: payment app you want to be able to make
Caption: a payment what's next oh you might want
Caption: to schedule the payment and then what's
Caption: next you might want to do multiple of
Caption: those and you want them to recur so
Caption: that's just a way for users and whoever
Caption: interacts with this feature tree to go
Caption: that's a pretty simple way of me
Caption: understanding what are all the things I
Caption: can do in this product and you stagger
Caption: those features and you'll see some of
Caption: them connect they can get pretty curly
Caption: pretty quickly but it's it's intended to
Caption: be a simple communication artifact
Caption: so if we Zoom all the way out you'll see
Caption: this long complicated map of features if
Caption: you will so divided by columns sometimes
Caption: even by priority or by rows the order in
Caption: which it's been delivered but it may
Caption: look like a really sophisticated
Caption: complicated map
Caption: and you might think this is a bank it's
Caption: a public facing product why are they
Caption: making this sort of that transparent I
Caption: think it's pretty cool for products to
Caption: be so radically out there and say these
Caption: are the things I've done so the firstly
Caption: allows people to navigate that map and
Caption: see these are all the cool things I can
Caption: do for example you want the API to hook
Caption: in to get all your payment data you want
Caption: to do some fancy graphs with it you can
Caption: do that because it's lower down on the
Caption: feature tree and you can see that that's
Caption: only for some obsessive people not like
Caption: me but it can also see what's up next
Caption: for example
Caption: so having that accountability publishing
Caption: this online this is a fully interactive
Caption: website super high fidelity I'm not here
Caption: today to tell you this is what we're
Caption: aspiring to when we're doing feature
Caption: trees but it exposes a concept to me at
Caption: least pretty beautifully so if you're
Caption: thinking this is super complicated it's
Caption: very messy it's a lot of detailed it's
Caption: actually in my estimation just supposed
Caption: to be a really well organized list so I
Caption: want to play a quick game by a show of
Caption: hands a common list we all use which is
Caption: our shopping lists right so
Caption: it's a game so put your hand up for me
Caption: if you before you go grocery shopping if
Caption: you even make a list
Caption: okay good you all then just go rock up
Caption: then opportunistic please keep your
Caption: hands up for me
Caption: so now keep your hand up for me if you
Caption: organize that list somehow
Caption: a few hands might drop okay we got some
Caption: people they love it okay now next
Caption: question keep your hand up again for me
Caption: if you organize that list by the floor
Caption: plan of your favorite grocery store
Caption: okay here we go okay so you're kind of
Caption: using your shopping list as a bit of a
Caption: map right so that helps you navigate
Caption: your grocery store final question for
Caption: now then I can let you put your arms
Caption: down so keep your hands up again and one
Caption: or two people might actually put their
Caption: hands up again
Caption: keep your hands up if you organize your
Caption: shopping list deliberately the keyword
Caption: is deliberately so that it can be used
Caption: in any grocery store
Caption: purple is hiring so come chat to us
Caption: afterwards that'll be great no so the
Caption: only concept I wanted to explore there
Caption: is you might then be using your shopping
Caption: list as a compass something that allows
Caption: you to navigate or respond to the
Caption: environment you're in so we're going to
Caption: live a little bit in metaphor territory
Caption: what is a feature tree is it a map is it
Caption: a compass I'm here to tell you why not
Caption: both so typically when we see a feature
Caption: tree a list a very simple well-organized
Caption: list I see one of those old school maps
Caption: that you fold out it's a static fixed
Caption: environment you think at least at that
Caption: point in time you know your environment
Caption: that is just your articulation I guess
Caption: of what we know now and what we've built
Caption: what we're currently building and what's
Caption: up next sometimes even just arriving at
Caption: that is sort of the destination that
Caption: process
Caption: but is it a compass how does a featured
Caption: tree act as a compass to help us
Caption: navigate the the colorful you know Seas
Caption: or world that is navigating this product
Caption: space
Caption: and that is if you've got that Baseline
Caption: that document that setup that allows you
Caption: to say right this is my product these
Caption: are the features these are all the the
Caption: functionality that exist if for example
Caption: introducing new functionality you've got
Caption: that visual artifact that allows you to
Caption: negotiate a little bit if I have this I
Caption: won't be getting this or that fits in
Caption: here or these things relate especially
Caption: when there's multiple teams
Caption: communicating around for example a
Caption: product backlog and that you have that
Caption: summary piece that accompanies it so it
Caption: might sound a little bit like apologetic
Caption: this is not to like the most crazy outer
Caption: topic ever but it's such a nice way of
Caption: just surfacing coming up for air from a
Caption: product backlog so I mentioned product
Caption: backlog let's look at one so this is a
Caption: common backlog what you don't have to do
Caption: today is critique the user stories here
Caption: you can I didn't write them so I'll join
Caption: you so um this is just an example of
Caption: user stories in a backlog that
Caption: developers would commonly use to build
Caption: certain functionality on the right this
Caption: is the product called jira I like the
Caption: example here because it at least
Caption: visually color codes all that green
Caption: stories on the right I think they relate
Caption: to one another and they form a feature
Caption: set you can't scroll here but I can so
Caption: for example when I scrolled down you can
Caption: see okay there's multiple stories here
Caption: so we're working on a piece of
Caption: functionality for that feature here here
Caption: so it does go into that space but
Caption: sometimes it's not as visual so this is
Caption: another deliberately sort of small
Caption: um a screenshot here let's just for
Caption: example say that first one to seven
Caption: stories here if you understand this
Caption: product it's all in the realm of like I
Caption: get it it's maybe a value on a page and
Caption: when was it last updated things like
Caption: that so this back to the shopping
Caption: experience is for example I'm in the
Caption: Woolworths in Palmyra I'm there I'll
Caption: just grab a basket I know I need bread
Caption: and eggs I think I know what needs to
Caption: happen Story one two seven all of a
Caption: sudden shout out to my partner Jeff she
Caption: calls me I've got a basket by the the
Caption: way can you buy eight watermelons for me
Caption: and I'm like I don't have hashtag scope
Caption: for eight watermelons in my basket it's
Caption: gonna smash the bread I'm wearing a mask
Caption: I'm gonna sneeze straight up a bad time
Caption: no one likes that kind of a surprise
Caption: if we had a feature tree you could say
Caption: for example that is a really high effort
Caption: or high value feature visualized that
Caption: way you're gonna run through a quick you
Caption: know quick fire of stories over here but
Caption: there is that big thing coming our way
Caption: that story in this example was just
Caption: casually create an iOS version of the
Caption: app and we were like okay cool cool cool
Caption: um so here's another example I say does
Caption: it hurt yet I'm humoring designers
Caption: sometimes we're asked to just hand over
Caption: a um
Caption: all of the research we've done so just
Caption: quickly give me all the business
Caption: requirements and we'll build it detail
Caption: has a home I absolutely love detail but
Caption: this is not that if you pull me into a
Caption: meeting with no notice what have you
Caption: done where are we at what are we
Caption: building this does not give you that so
Caption: all I'm saying is this has a place
Caption: especially when it comes to the Tactical
Caption: strategic or Vision or system level
Caption: transformation that detail for me lives
Caption: all the way in the Tactical don't you
Caption: dare this over discover things that are
Caption: three four five years away because it's
Caption: gonna go stale so what a feature tree
Caption: does really well for me is
Caption: um support this the detail that we've
Caption: discovered and then it visualizes that
Caption: neatly where it fits in and it supports
Caption: the delivery of the backlog so it
Caption: represents the work it's the sum of
Caption: what's in the backlog in a more visual
Caption: way so that's kind of the theory bit
Caption: over I guess so introducing you to what
Caption: it is let's go into why I think it's
Caption: awesome it's good for me to give a get a
Caption: layer of the land like who is here in
Caption: the room so I might ask you or online
Caption: with my mom in South Africa is watching
Caption: hello Melinda
Caption: um so we've got four groups here crudely
Caption: summarized right crudely summarized if
Caption: you're not in one of these groups pick
Caption: one but I just want a quick show of
Caption: hands so designers
Caption: um my fan club over there thank you
Caption: awesome okay so Developers
Caption: that could be data there's really well
Caption: represented awesome and product owners
Caption: or product people anyone in that space
Caption: awesome and then projects stakeholders
Caption: whatever that means awesome colorful
Caption: okay so I'll try and skew towards the
Caption: dev side of things if my you know
Caption: abilities allow so I want to take you
Caption: through my experience of exposing or
Caption: introducing this as an artifact to these
Caption: four groups
Caption: what changes I brought about or what
Caption: kinds of problems does it solve I'll
Caption: also on the right of each of these
Caption: slides to show you some of the examples
Caption: that I've worked on I may have had a
Caption: direct hand in some of them or my team
Caption: the fan club over there may have created
Caption: some of it so if you've got any
Caption: questions yeah if you love them let me
Caption: know if you don't
Caption: so let's jump into why designers love it
Caption: you can all read the bullets as well so
Caption: I'll do some storytelling around the
Caption: bullets but the first thing we do is
Caption: often when we are introduced I work in a
Caption: Consulting capacity so
Caption: when we're introduced to a new problem
Caption: you might go through some rapid research
Caption: or my favorite is the research has been
Caption: done can you just make it look pretty so
Caption: we might end up for example with a
Caption: pretty prototype it's clickable it's
Caption: real it feels good the designer smashed
Caption: it
Caption: but there's so much more value about
Caption: going through that process sincerely and
Caption: in depth you gain a lot of context so
Caption: the first bullet there is it allows us
Caption: to share the context far beyond just the
Caption: pretty pictures because the second we
Caption: ask some of the questions is that system
Caption: ready to give us the data we think we
Caption: need for that feature day one no it's
Caption: not okay is it still a valuable problem
Caption: to solve yes okay well we might untangle
Caption: the Prototype ever so slightly and that
Caption: might be represented by the order in
Caption: which we organize our thought so again
Caption: pretty simple content but it is nice for
Caption: us to at least then go if I just want to
Caption: do the right thing for the users and for
Caption: the products owners and stackers that
Caption: kind of thing you want to be able to at
Caption: least organize your thought in a way
Caption: where you can systematically feel like
Caption: the goal posts are not moving you at
Caption: least just slowly summing to that
Caption: experience perfect example of when
Caption: things change you can adjust it allows
Caption: you to find Discovery gaps so my
Caption: favorite is go Tada I'm done and then a
Caption: developer will be like well I okay
Caption: you're close but not so have you thought
Caption: about that that way does this go where
Caption: does bat go and all that stuff so that's
Caption: a really good example for me where I can
Caption: then go back and say
Caption: cool let me add that to my future Trio
Caption: story on that feature tree if you will
Caption: and go I'll go back and I'll go
Caption: um do some Discovery and lastly like
Caption: I've probably already mentioned it gives
Caption: us a bit of a seat at the strategy chat
Caption: so I'm being lazy with the wording
Caption: strategy chats but when you've
Caption: discovered stuff you understand user
Caption: problems you might think that the
Caption: roadmap that was agreed to six months
Caption: ago is still up to date it's probably
Caption: not it allows us to give some input in
Caption: that reprioritization of work because
Caption: we've done some of that discovery
Caption: so from a development perspective should
Caption: be no surprise to you I'm not a
Caption: developer so I'll try but this is what
Caption: my colleagues at Telstra purple have
Caption: mentioned it's helpful for so especially
Caption: when you're a say for example it's a
Caption: really long development gig it's a
Caption: really established product onboarding a
Caption: new team member it's awesome so the
Caption: example here on the right would be lots
Caption: of different features of a product I'm
Caption: sure you can put together who it's for
Caption: and what it is so let's assume some of
Caption: those features that could for example
Caption: say you see that feature you know the
Caption: second one from the left I've worked on
Caption: that feature all of these Green Dots I
Caption: built that with my own bare hands and My
Caption: Blood Sweat and Tears and this is what
Caption: I've learned when I did that oh you're
Caption: going to join me working on that feature
Caption: fantastic ignore the rest for now but if
Caption: you ever encounter something go look for
Caption: it find it in it at least at the very
Caption: least it allows you to navigate a bit of
Caption: that uncertainty because I don't think a
Caption: product backlog if you want to run some
Caption: fancy report of all the stories that
Caption: were done where all the high story
Caption: pointers which are the ones that dragged
Caption: on six prints longer than of that kind
Caption: of drama in a backlog maybe it doesn't
Caption: give that story but at least this helps
Caption: you to come up for air and tell that
Caption: story a little bit
Caption: so it visualizes the elastic scope and
Caption: progress
Caption: so we'll get into how we even get to
Caption: this point but again often taking a
Caption: backlog and trying organizing it in a
Caption: way that does conveniently over
Caption: summarize always use that word
Caption: conveniently because someone is just
Caption: just tell me what I need to know like
Caption: but there's so much leader so if the
Caption: point of getting here if your backlog is
Caption: in a bit of a state because sometimes it
Caption: is and again teams like things the way
Caption: that they like them so if you're
Caption: changing teams onboarded a new team
Caption: member and you want to sort of reflect
Caption: to how that team likes to work and
Caption: organize themselves then if the backlog
Caption: is a mess your feature tree will be a
Caption: mess but yeah call me toxically positive
Caption: but that's an opportunity for a feature
Caption: tree so you can reorganize that work
Caption: then so that for the most bit for the
Caption: almost everyone working on this product
Caption: or an example of up if you want to so so
Caption: radically put yourself out there and
Caption: make it that ultimate accountability of
Caption: here's what I'm doing it visualizes that
Caption: and it just allows you to say this is
Caption: what I've done this is what I'm doing
Caption: and this is what's coming up next
Caption: the last bullet here empowers autonomy
Caption: is a bit like what a designer feels like
Caption: but I've got input to give into the
Caption: order because users want this more than
Caption: what you think they wanted there or
Caption: months ago similar story here in that if
Caption: we've got a specific feature especially
Caption: things that are two or three or four
Caption: Sprints ahead and we say this is a bit
Caption: of functionality that we want to develop
Caption: but a product owner had a brilliant idea
Caption: overnight or promised some functionality
Caption: at a pub last night whatever story it
Caption: rings through then you want to introduce
Caption: new functionality then or immediately a
Caption: developer would say for example with a
Caption: feature tree okay you see all of this
Caption: functionality we've got over here I
Caption: don't think we've got time or the
Caption: Technical Resources for example to get
Caption: any of that if we introduce that and it
Caption: just facilitates that needful
Caption: conversation about always you know
Caption: keeping the what's next in Focus so that
Caption: you can you can focus on that while
Caption: having a plan for what's to come so
Caption: that's why I like them in that context
Caption: as well
Caption: so let's keep the head there why product
Caption: owners love it they're not not just
Caption: product owners it's people working on
Caption: products in that product since in its
Caption: broadest possible colorful meaning
Caption: if it's multiple trees is it a feature
Caption: Forest who knows so this could be
Caption: multiple feature trees and what we do
Caption: here for example again not my project
Caption: but it was used to affect the air more
Caption: in the map context let's just visualize
Caption: what we're doing a big big stream of
Caption: work with multiple teams working on
Caption: multiple things so it can get complex
Caption: quite quickly but what we're trying to
Caption: do is get a lay or visualize it this is
Caption: an online whiteboarding tool doesn't
Caption: always have to be presentation ready if
Caption: you will but it doesn't even it can even
Caption: be a scribble but just have a
Caption: visualization of everything we're
Caption: working on and that's where the color
Caption: coding here comes in we've built all of
Caption: this stuff this is getting for example
Caption: data from a platform that we're retiring
Caption: in six months we're gonna have holes
Caption: here and this is what's coming up and
Caption: what that also allows people to do for
Caption: example is budget Cycles
Caption: but they exist so how much casola do you
Caption: need for the next 12 months okay cool
Caption: let's do a very cursory estimate I think
Caption: will focus on this section let's see if
Caption: we've got the right people the right
Caption: skill sets the right time allotted and
Caption: things like that and then you can do an
Caption: estimate on something like this so if
Caption: you're a product owner working on
Caption: multiple products think of a way that at
Caption: least we can dive into the detail from
Caption: here or come up for air and at least
Caption: depending on which direction in your
Caption: organization you kind of tell the story
Caption: of your product
Caption: and then why project people are again I
Caption: refuse the words they go to the sound so
Caption: clunky but then here's me again cross
Caption: capability streams of work anyway so
Caption: cross capability streams of work
Caption: um if you've got multiple teams again
Caption: with multiple skill sets there might be
Caption: a team for example here in Perth say if
Caption: we've got a team over East and they're
Caption: working on a piece of functionality
Caption: maybe their own team wants their own
Caption: backlog you might actually separate
Caption: different backlogs for things like this
Caption: but you're at least able to organize
Caption: work in the way that you want and then
Caption: visualize it accordingly so very easily
Caption: we could say that column on the far
Caption: right that's actually you know the team
Caption: in Sydney that one is the team in
Caption: Melbourne this is the Perth team for
Caption: example you could do things like that as
Caption: well I've mentioned the color coding a
Caption: few times now it's just a simple
Caption: artifact think of it as like a traffic
Caption: sort of light system
Caption: it sets expectations in a way as well in
Caption: public facing products so for example
Caption: there's a new piece of functionality we
Caption: want to get the marketing team involved
Caption: to celebrate the the launch of something
Caption: for example they need to know when they
Caption: need to get ready that kind of thing so
Caption: you could for example have ready to
Caption: launch and then that team could say okay
Caption: they'll change the color once there
Caption: things are in order but this is very
Caption: much focused on the development of the
Caption: product and what's live for a user today
Caption: and then a small underrated feature as
Caption: well you'll probably discover some other
Caption: ones as well but it can link directly to
Caption: a product backlog as well I don't know
Caption: how many organizations allow the people
Caption: to come in and leave notes on user
Caption: stories and stuff like that depending on
Caption: your culture depending on where you are
Caption: but people can always ask questions
Caption: especially if they've got helpful input
Caption: so that one little random dot over there
Caption: that looks interesting what's that about
Caption: you can just sort of put brackets at the
Caption: end put the user Story ID they usually
Caption: have numbers hyperlink that you click on
Caption: that it opens if you not been blocked
Caption: from the project so it should open so
Caption: that's sort of how these different user
Caption: groups have benefit from there you'll
Caption: also see one column there again not my
Caption: specific project or feature tree but in
Caption: this instance arriving at this
Caption: complicated feature tree was a great way
Caption: of just visualizing the sheer volume of
Caption: work we think we've committed to but the
Caption: spoilers none of this can always happen
Caption: before say August that year so there was
Caption: a column an entire feature where they
Caption: said if we want something that is
Caption: polished end-to-end vertically slides
Caption: it's got the full real piece of
Caption: functionality let's de-prioritize some
Caption: functionality on the right so that was
Caption: my understanding how this was of impact
Caption: for that specific product
Caption: when do we plant feature trees I love
Caption: these metaphors so you can either in a
Caption: Consulting context often there's a need
Caption: for one so we we work with an existing
Caption: product again even the process of
Caption: onboarding an entirely new team to a
Caption: product they may want just to use it as
Caption: part of their intuition building phase
Caption: you know any two three four Sprints at
Caption: time you will need to build intuition
Caption: about a product spoilers make a feature
Caption: tree because you could organize your own
Caption: thought you can replay your
Caption: understanding to someone that's been on
Caption: the project for a long while it's going
Caption: to have to iterate a few times but
Caption: there's that magic point of like oh okay
Caption: we see it the same way and that's really
Caption: a good point where people can start
Caption: becoming autonomous in their decisions
Caption: and things like that
Caption: but spoilers is usually about this at
Caption: least from some of our experiences
Caption: that's why I use the fire extinguisher
Caption: on the right I use the knife for me when
Caption: you've done a polished I mentioned
Caption: before we've done this polished
Caption: prototype it looks beautiful it's
Caption: awesome now we need to answer those
Caption: difficult questions of how do we make it
Caption: real how do we cut pieces of
Caption: functionality and that's why I like the
Caption: knife so we call it story slicing so
Caption: let's go into the first example
Caption: of how you grow one when you're working
Caption: with an existing backlog so you've got
Caption: your backlog hopefully it might be a two
Caption: like jira or Azure devops you might use
Caption: like a kanban style thing like Trello
Caption: for example if you're using this in a
Caption: non-product space just to organize your
Caption: shopping lists for example some of you
Caption: so um if you you take your list whatever
Caption: list you have it's probably in a tool
Caption: somewhere command or control I export
Caption: CSV get it in a workable format so now
Caption: at least you're not distracted by what
Caption: it is you just have a clean list of what
Caption: it is
Caption: now you can probably make a decision do
Caption: you work in a physical copy or a digital
Caption: copy so there's lots of awesome digital
Caption: tools
Caption: if your team if you sense we're not
Caption: aligned we can't talk about the backlog
Caption: in the same way as in you cringe when
Caption: people think they mentioned the
Caption: priorities in a little bit of do this
Caption: together but do it in person so I would
Caption: recommend you know those nice 3M the
Caption: ones with the nice glue use physical
Caption: Post-it notes and then write one Post-It
Caption: note per user story so you've got your
Caption: backlog with a long list of user stories
Caption: I've seen six seven eight hundred long
Caption: story backlogs
Caption: you did this to yourself write it all
Caption: out okay so now we've got Post-it notes
Caption: of all of our user stories
Caption: in the world of user research there's
Caption: this activity we like to call card
Caption: sorting it's typically used to sort the
Caption: information architecture or the way that
Caption: users navigate it's just what people
Caption: commonly associate with for example
Caption: features or Pages or things like that
Caption: and it's essentially like playing snap
Caption: with your inside so what you want to do
Caption: is I've got you just start sequentially
Caption: maybe even hand a couple of Post-it
Caption: notes out to the team do this sort of in
Caption: a workshop format and say right you've
Caption: got a Post-It note there read it out
Caption: that's that one you go next is it the
Caption: same or is it different if you're
Caption: working from your product backlog
Caption: sequentially first story to last it
Caption: might be clear in the beginning but it
Caption: might unravel towards the end so trick
Caption: shuffle them up and then start fresh so
Caption: we're not anchored by the thought that
Caption: went into it but if if it's good load
Caption: keep it work from the top so just do
Caption: what's right for your team but over time
Caption: what's going to emerge are these
Caption: hopefully organic hopefully intuitive
Caption: groups of sets of features and that's
Caption: what can start forming the headers of
Caption: your feature tree so my biggest tip I
Caption: can give you as well steal from what's
Caption: real yo so you've got if it's an
Caption: existing product you can probably
Caption: already navigate through it so it's got
Caption: a home page it's got in the up example a
Caption: payments page an information section
Caption: it's got all of that already if you're
Caption: struggling to synthesize that's the word
Caption: we use to gather thought if you're
Caption: struggling to synthesize all of these
Caption: Post-it notes into Mass sort of adopted
Caption: or intuitive headings just take from
Caption: what you have it's it's perfectly fine
Caption: if you're designing a more internal
Caption: facing product and it's a business
Caption: process like a Nifty little payroll
Caption: chatbot or one of those cool ideas
Caption: people come up with all the time you
Caption: might just have steps to your approval
Caption: process just leverage what's real start
Caption: there and over time allow your tree to
Caption: grow so we've got the next one Focus now
Caption: specifically for example on the pile of
Caption: the green Post-it notes that's just an
Caption: arbitrary visual example but we've got a
Caption: set this is a feature we're focusing on
Caption: that feature now is the good time to ask
Caption: does this actually make sense so we've
Caption: got a feature let's use the app example
Caption: again payments
Caption: they may want to integrate in future
Caption: with more payment platforms add new
Caption: stories it's not detailed stories I'm
Caption: not talking about all of the requirement
Caption: Gatherings I'm just mentioning a mental
Caption: placeholder for all the things you still
Caption: want to add to that feature because
Caption: that's a bit more representative of what
Caption: you want to do in that space and at the
Caption: same time if there's Monkey Business in
Caption: there
Caption: cut it just get rid of it it's probably
Caption: the hardest thing to do for people to
Caption: separate with just this Legacy things
Caption: that every new team there's just that
Caption: bottom of the style bottom of the
Caption: backlog just get rid of it if you're not
Caption: comfortable crashing it completely put
Caption: it in a section like de-prioritized
Caption: maybe there is going to be that
Caption: investment that's going to unlock a new
Caption: platform that allows that feature to
Caption: then become prioritize hold on to it
Caption: especially if there is some usable
Caption: Discovery that's been done on it or
Caption: prototypes or things like that hold on
Caption: to it you can do that again with your
Caption: entire team present I would highly
Caption: recommend at least representatives of
Caption: all those groups that I've mentioned
Caption: before because then we can start that
Caption: conversation but what it does it builds
Caption: context of the content in the backlog
Caption: really nicely it could take a bit of
Caption: time if you've got a really really big
Caption: product but stagger it maybe have a
Caption: focus session for each of these features
Caption: so you stagger them out and lastly now
Caption: pull it together simple right easy so
Caption: this is not a talk about prioritization
Caption: that's a whole separate talk so how we
Caption: go about prioritizing stories but let's
Caption: look at the output of prioritization
Caption: that is the order in which we're doing
Caption: things per feature so that's where the
Caption: order of the feature streets feature
Caption: Tree starts coming in what are we doing
Caption: first from a specific feature organize
Caption: that top to bottom and then left to
Caption: right on your feature that could be in
Caption: onto the user Journey it could be hinged
Caption: under the highest value features or the
Caption: features that have the only earliest
Caption: Milestone date whatever order makes
Caption: sense for you so we've got all of our
Caption: green Post-it notes and we order them
Caption: and all of our other buckets everyone
Caption: loves sort of a junk drawer have an
Caption: other bucket be kind to yourself
Caption: when you're pulling this together that
Caption: little asterisk if you spotted it
Caption: that's the things to keep in mind so
Caption: lots of words on a slide here sorry not
Caption: sorry so the first thing to do is who is
Caption: your audience of your featured tree
Caption: don't be too ambitious because that puts
Caption: pressure of making something like this
Caption: I'll acknowledge that it is a bit of
Caption: manual effort to get started at first
Caption: this is 2022 who knows maybe it's the
Caption: next feature for them to work on saying
Caption: jira to have the ability if you sort
Caption: your stories right to automate something
Caption: like this wouldn't this be awesome so
Caption: we're going to look back at this talk
Caption: and be like oh that's the cassette tape
Caption: or the floppy disk of 2022 so um but
Caption: this side who is the audience of your
Caption: feature Tree in apps case they went bold
Caption: they said it's the public we want to
Caption: keep ourselves accountable to that
Caption: that's the kind of product centered or
Caption: culture that we want to drive for but if
Caption: you've got a leave a leave booking chat
Caption: Bots you probably won't do that so just
Caption: start small be humble be you know begin
Caption: small and then answer the next question
Caption: is it at the right level of detail we've
Caption: got on your feature tree typically it's
Caption: the product you might want to go epics
Caption: and in a list of features a branch for
Caption: each story or we've got even a lower
Caption: level of detail to a story could be
Caption: something like a task depending on what
Caption: structure if this test steps you might
Caption: sometimes use as a task in your Azure
Caption: backlog for example decide what's right
Caption: for the team
Caption: don't start too detailed we love detail
Caption: when we start something because we just
Caption: want that confidence that it is in there
Caption: but if we are engaged in the process
Caption: it's okay to drop some of the detail off
Caption: and just visualize it so then we need to
Caption: answer
Caption: what format is Right designers in the
Caption: room don't do it in illustrator because
Caption: then you automatically become the owner
Caption: because you're the only one that can
Caption: edit it use a tool that is easily
Caption: editable so like a mural of the world or
Caption: I say Miro you say Miro or fig Jam
Caption: there's lots of online whiteboarding
Caption: tools that's actually quite accessible
Caption: to use it's shareable with the URL you
Caption: can make it sort of semi public and you
Caption: can just change the Post-it notes as
Caption: they go the last two is also related to
Caption: one another is who will own it you might
Caption: think that it's intuitive for a single
Caption: person to own it like a product owner
Caption: you own a product unit you own it you
Caption: update it it's a lot of work if you not
Caption: maintaining it so if it's just a map if
Caption: it's just a point in time document you
Caption: can probably go a bit detailed but
Caption: acknowledge that Simon has a PDF don't
Caption: even tempt people to think it's quickly
Caption: editable because there is a lot of
Caption: detail on it I will acknowledge but if
Caption: it is something that you're embedding
Caption: for example in your agile ceremonies so
Caption: for example a common two-week Sprint
Caption: structure at the end you might have a
Caption: bit of a showcase that ah these are all
Caption: the stuff we did we thought we would do
Caption: we didn't get through it's at that point
Caption: in time if it's hopefully set up in a
Caption: format where you can just quickly change
Caption: the colors of the Post-it notes maybe
Caption: once a month move the order if things
Caption: change but if we embed it in our agile
Caption: ceremonies it's a really nice way to
Caption: start a Sprint showcase especially if
Caption: there are broader stakeholders in that
Caption: group I said the word so if there's
Caption: other people in a showcase that might
Caption: not have the lowest level of detail oh
Caption: so where are we on the chatbot and then
Caption: you could say cool we've started that
Caption: for example visually and then go into
Caption: the more detail which is yeah sharing
Caption: some of that so I'll speed up a bit so
Caption: now we're working with a new backlog a
Caption: new product we've just done Discovery
Caption: there is a brand new shiny prototype how
Caption: do we stare at a blank screen and go
Caption: where do we start that's very
Caption: intimidating I'll admit even for me so
Caption: the five E's of service design like if
Caption: this is an educational talk this is a
Caption: thing I might expose you to who knows
Caption: but the five ease of service design is
Caption: just a construct that service designers
Caption: like myself use to navigate a user
Caption: journey and spoilers it's so simple so
Caption: hopefully you can use some of it before
Caption: I jump into what they are and we again
Caption: you map out the user journey and how to
Caption: translate that to a backlog I just want
Caption: to share an example
Caption: I want to say again deliberately low
Caption: quality but I didn't have access to this
Caption: anymore so I just took a screenshot of
Caption: what I have but here what we'll see is a
Caption: problem that we solved for a wi insurer
Caption: so what they were trying to do is
Caption: um release functionality so that their
Caption: users can cancel their insurance policy
Caption: online now questions asked go in press
Caption: cancel it's done instant refund in our
Caption: research what was really awesome is
Caption: there's no other insurer to our
Caption: knowledge that allows you to do that in
Caption: Australia so represent wa which is
Caption: awesome
Caption: um but we needed to design for an
Caption: experience here and after we had our
Caption: prototype we were able to arrive semi at
Caption: this point so I'll set you through some
Caption: of the detail and then I'll get to the
Caption: five is how you can remember the
Caption: structure for yourself if you're trying
Caption: to do something like this
Caption: so on the left that first feature this
Caption: is a working draft the early days the
Caption: ugly version of a feature tree and
Caption: that's okay I don't even think we
Caption: iterated the Fidelity after this we kind
Caption: of just kept it kind of there it served
Caption: its purpose
Caption: access how do users get into this
Caption: experience let's talk about it as a form
Caption: so how do users access this cancellation
Caption: form so these are all the things we're
Caption: considering today they've got a platform
Caption: a portal you can log into let's leverage
Caption: a cancel button there lots of cool ideas
Caption: we have in the future but we stagger
Caption: them out focus on Priority First the
Caption: next four so the view policy details of
Caption: course you want to be sure you're
Caption: canceling the right policy so let's pull
Caption: up that information that's where the
Caption: interesting stuff starts presenting
Caption: information in a simple way that's
Caption: relevant to that place you've just
Caption: clicked from you want to select the
Caption: cancellation reason this is not just an
Caption: information grab it depends on the
Caption: reason you're canceling depends on your
Caption: refund and the terms and conditions and
Caption: stuff like that it also helps the
Caption: customer service of course then there's
Caption: the date and the refund so we want to
Caption: know when are you can select from
Caption: depending on your reason there's some
Caption: rules and depending on what um what kind
Caption: of policy you have your refund amount
Caption: might look different shout out to my
Caption: Boomers some of them pay cash once a
Caption: year that's a whole other refund Journey
Caption: than the online credit card ones so for
Caption: example these are all the things we
Caption: needed to navigate and we're like right
Caption: there's you know lots of different user
Caption: groups and things like that editing your
Caption: details might as well you're there and
Caption: in the confirmation so what I'm taking
Caption: you through is the user journey of for
Caption: example the end result of our Discovery
Caption: and that's how we chunked it up for our
Caption: backlog so if you want the ability to
Caption: recall or replicate something like this
Caption: for yourself
Caption: this is where the five ease of service
Caption: design come in I'm not starting at the
Caption: first one I'll tell you in a second why
Caption: but let's go with that second one enter
Caption: every Journey starts somewhere right our
Caption: first pillar was purely this is a user
Caption: based or user journey-based feature tree
Caption: how do we access our experience what's
Caption: that entry point and we already said
Caption: there's existing portal our initial
Caption: release the minimum viable product hate
Caption: that word
Caption: um is we're just pressing a button and
Caption: we're entering that experience and
Caption: that's why it's at the top enter
Caption: the next four like I mentioned that's
Caption: engage so any user Journey again that
Caption: you'll go through in life has these
Caption: characters engaged that's the core of it
Caption: so you'll probably have quite a few
Caption: features in that if it's a form it's the
Caption: pages of the form if it's a leave
Caption: booking chatbot it's the approval stage
Caption: Gates whatever you need like I've
Caption: already mentioned every feature that
Caption: exists has stories associated with it
Caption: and then finally your confirmations your
Caption: exits beginning middle end
Caption: um and enter and guide X so those three
Caption: is there the core so I like to think of
Caption: the exits as your planned and your
Caption: unplanned successes and failures so
Caption: what's your plan success oh that's just
Caption: a confirmation message you're getting
Caption: almost all of your money back in seven
Caption: days awesome you get the text message
Caption: for reinsurance fantastic or the
Caption: unplanned failures could be your error
Caption: messages you need that to go live of
Caption: course day one but there's other cool
Caption: things later down the line office in
Caption: service design we find a little bit of
Caption: back of house manual stuff we're willing
Caption: to cope with to release this to test if
Caption: people actually want to use it and over
Caption: time we might invest in automating some
Caption: of that and that's where the book ends
Caption: come in and ties and extend don't like
Caption: to start at entice an extent because
Caption: that's usually when the big picture
Caption: thinkers get really excited what are all
Caption: the cool ways we can attract users to
Caption: these features and extend what are all
Caption: the ways that we can make a linear
Caption: Journey or a product Journey circular
Caption: and things like that don't start there
Caption: but acknowledge that these are typically
Caption: from my experience at least lower down
Caption: the priority list when we're launching
Caption: new functionality constantly
Caption: re-prioritized but in ties how do we get
Caption: more users to that journey and extend
Caption: now what do we want to automate more
Caption: what does this unlock that kind of
Caption: thinking
Caption: so just
Caption: teaching by sheer repetition the five
Caption: ease of service designs start in that
Caption: metal beginning middle and end then I
Caption: would say answer those questions what
Caption: comes before and what comes after so if
Caption: we've got a user Journey that is usually
Caption: how we can look at our prototype
Caption: now cut slice that's where the knife
Caption: comes in slice the prototype in that
Caption: user Journey how does it answer that
Caption: question and then we look at the
Caption: experience and do the story breakdown
Caption: from there
Caption: so what we're looking at here like I've
Caption: mentioned already is at the beginning of
Caption: a feature tree all of the smaller
Caption: Post-it notes they're color coded for
Caption: various reasons like still needs
Caption: Discovery that's a different team that's
Caption: where we blocked by a platform but at
Caption: the very least and this is the other way
Caption: it's the first time I've tried this so
Caption: bonus cornalism for you why not road map
Caption: it so we mapped out this is the core
Caption: piece of functionality we're going to go
Caption: live with day one what does the second
Caption: release look like you want more but yeah
Caption: second release or the phase after that
Caption: and where we discovered where is our
Caption: save for later bucket and that's how we
Caption: use the feature tree to give that
Caption: product vision and then we can create
Caption: the backlog from here and then we've got
Caption: structure in a backlog you can tag your
Caption: backlog then with your feature Flags or
Caption: things like that and color coded and
Caption: these artifacts will continue if you
Caption: update your feature tree they live
Caption: together you update the feature tree you
Caption: update your backlog you update your
Caption: backlog you update your feature tree so
Caption: in high periods of change pause the one
Caption: definitely sort the house out the
Caption: backlog out or sort the feature tree out
Caption: which one you're more dominant in and
Caption: then make sure that the other one
Caption: reflects this change because then we can
Caption: navigate between the two
Caption: so I made you all a template so this is
Caption: just a basic PowerPoint template a lot
Caption: of what you saw today is um just
Caption: PowerPoint templates it's not overly
Caption: fancy so I've created one hopefully this
Caption: QR code still works from overnight I've
Caption: not tested it this morning and this QR
Caption: code is only going to be live today so
Caption: shout out to the future if you're
Caption: watching this it's not going to work so
Caption: um I'll send you a couple of resources
Caption: I'll send you that how to make one slide
Caption: and if the five E's of service design in
Caption: this PowerPoint
Caption: um template that I've made it's also on
Caption: the next slide so I'm going to move on
Caption: I've I've been given my five minute time
Caption: warning sorry if I went a bit over but
Caption: at this point I might say thank you
Caption: again for the 900th time and ask if
Caption: you've got any questions and hopefully
Caption: we can navigate that or I'll be probably
Caption: throughout today at the Telstra purple
Caption: Booth if you want to have a chat so
Caption: any questions any opportunities
Caption: it's all good we've got a question here
Caption: what is my favorite tool to work in for
Caption: feature trees it really depends on the
Caption: project Story Time the most recent
Caption: feature to you I've created was in Excel
Caption: because our product owner absolutely
Caption: loved Excel so it has the ability to
Caption: filter and sort and give details and if
Caption: you export a backlog so for example in
Caption: our case Azure devops it already is in a
Caption: similar format so you can manipulate
Caption: that CSV for that run reporting off of
Caption: it it intimidates some team members
Caption: because they're allergic to Excel and
Caption: that's okay so then at that point my
Caption: experiences you make the trade-off I
Caption: love the online whiteboarding tools I
Caption: work from home so for me it's an easy
Caption: place if you can convince someone to
Caption: just go in and use it it's usually just
Caption: show me how you do it then they'll get
Caption: into it and see how easy it is and if
Caption: they're convinced that it's that easy
Caption: then they will but if you tell them
Caption: you're going to use a new tool they
Caption: might be a bit antsy but luckily for us
Caption: I guess in our process it's already
Caption: embedded that specific tool if you can
Caption: work online but
Caption: almost flipping the question don't let
Caption: the tool block you so an Excel can be a
Caption: bit oh sorry a PowerPoint can be quite
Caption: fidgety if you're moving a lot of
Caption: grouped boxes around no one's favorite
Caption: and choose an easy tool like a the
Caption: mirrors of the world or they're quite
Caption: easy I I find
Caption: awesome
Caption: there's a sorry I want to also mention
Caption: on that no
Caption: if you take an Excel spreadsheet and you
Caption: copy all the cells you have two windows
Caption: and you drag the Excel cells over to
Caption: mirror it just creates Post-it notes for
Caption: you it's a wickedly fast feature you'll
Caption: probably only believe it if you see it
Caption: but it's that quick it's actually really
Caption: cool so try it next time drag your
Caption: stories into these whiteboarding tools
Caption: do you have time for one more question
Caption: for one more
Caption: all good if not
Caption: there will be morning tea if there's no
Caption: more questions whether that influences
Caption: your decision to ask
Caption: awesome so that's me thanks first DDD
Caption: talk down
Caption: thank you everyone
Caption: [Applause]